these are the helipads Aton cave here at
the camp Radcliffe headquarters of the
1st Cavalry Division airmobile the
problem of excessive weight in airborne
command communications equipment is
being solved these technicians are
preparing to check out a recently
developed lightweight system installed
in this helicopter the newly designed
communication system weighs only 150
pounds as opposed to the previously used
600 pounds of equipment in addition this
lightweight unit provides the airborne
CP with two different radio frequencies
and a multiple outlet intercom known as
the a n AR c 122 the system is composed
of 2 a.m. DRC 46 radio receiver
transmitters and the intercom channel 3
with antennas not have beneath the
helicopter fuselage give the command
radio system a range of 24 to 32
kilometers in actual use on a combat
mission
the compact communications unit is
operated by the commander's s3 officer
and by an artillery fire support officer
the commander gives his orders to the
other officers and the helicopter pilot
via the intercom upon receiving the
orders of the commander the s3 relays
the message to ground commanders using
one of the two available channels
simultaneously the artillery officer can
be in contact with the FDC on the other
channel if desired an extremely flexible
command post in the sky
camp Radcliffe drops away in the
distance as the airborne CP heads for
the Central Highlands another Search and
Destroy mission is about to begin high
above the area where the assault troops
will establish a landing zone the
commander and his s3 evaluate the
terrain features below math coordinates
are studied in a low-level examination
of the surrounding countryside a
suspected Vietcong village is located it
is decided to call up an artillery fire
support mission in the immediate
vicinity of the landing zone on the
ground at the FDC the information is
received through a PRC 25 radio
telephone the mission is plotted using
the data received from the airborne CP a
phone call is then made to the battery
commander and he is given complete
firing data the m102 howitzer Tsar made
ready for the mission then the
lightweight air transportable tube
artillery goes into action
aboard the flying CP the commander
observes the shelling of the wooded
cover adjacent to the landing zone by
this time the assault helicopters are
arriving at the objective as the first
wave of choppers reaches the LZ troopers
of the 1st Air Cavalry Division leaped
to the ground and begin moving toward
the cover of the nearby wood line the
unit commander receives intelligence
from the airborne CP regarding the
unmapped village ahead and possible
location of the enemy a mortar crew sets
up its weapon and prepares to shell the
thick cover on the perimeter of their
position the information they have
received from the commander flying
overhead is checked against their map
then firing commences
in the air the artillery officer confers
with the commander the troops advancing
towards the village encountered dense
undergrowth and progress is slowed as
they push through clinging weeds and
brush all sense of direction can be lost
in the heavy vegetation a halt is called
while this platoon gets reoriented a
check is made with the airborne command
post to make sure the unit is moving in
the right direction
the airborne commander observing the
location of the troops issues corrective
instructions with compass and map the
platoon moves ahead reaching the village
shortly thereafter tunnels ever-present
in the villages of Vietnam are located
and searched for hidden enemy personnel
while the tunnel runner is below ground
security is provided by posted guards
this complex of underground passages
proves to be empty with a deserted
village behind them the flying cavalry
men moved to the LZ and signal for pick
up the Search and Destroy mission is
completed and soon the choppers arrive
to take the men out now satisfied that
there are no Vietcong in the area the
airborne commander also returns to anche
the modern communication system a na RC
122 has done its job well
at sunsalute airbase Saigon is a
heliport handling a high volume of
rotary wing aircraft traffic ranging
from the Sioux to the Chinook
helicopters these aircraft are largely
from army units based outside of Saigon
a control tower mobile van mounted on a
2 and 1/2 ton truck is used for
controlling the traffic here the wind
direction is being communicated by radio
to Huey helicopters preparing to land at
the Saigon halluf or also situated at
Taunton nuit is an army facility for the
maintenance of electric generators in
use by air traffic control personnel
throughout the earth nam here our
maintenance is performed on generators
of all sizes from one and a half to 15
kilowatt 60 cycle generators and the 400
cycle generators used to supply radar
system incoming generators are checked
deficiencies noted and the equipment
again put in a good operating condition
at the funk ow 125 kilometers southeast
of Saigon is an airfield in continual
use by fixed-wing and rotary-wing
aircraft traffic handling facilities
include a control tower and a ground
control approach radar system for use in
inclement weather this modern radar
system includes a means of identifying
Friend or Foe
I'm Colonel Aaron's CEO fourth
transportation command a part of the US
Army's first logged command in Vietnam
our mission is to run Saigon port
complex this includes the ports of
Saigon and sub port activities if nabe
in bung tau ships transit the river
system from vung tau area on up the
river to the nabe river and up here into
the Saigon River to reach Saigon port
here in Saigon part we handle general
cargo destined for all the Devils in the
Saigon area general cargo includes all
cargo other than bulk M ammunition and
bulk gasoline products here in Saigon we
bring ships up the river and berth them
at our birth facilities of which there
are six for the discharge of the vessels
onto the key side or we tie ships on
Anchorage on the boys for discharge onto
barge and by barge distribution through
the inland waterway system to the depot
sites we use a wide range of equipment
here in Saigon part ranging all the way
from small forklifts to 60 ton floating
cranes this equipment includes landing
craft patrol boats such as the one we're
on landing craft utilities barges
lighter Ridge tugs and other floating
craft additionally on the shore we use
light trucks heavy trucks trains
forklifts and a wide variety of
materials handling equipment generally
the cargo is moved from ship side onto
the key side on the trucks for port
clearance through to the DEF poles
located here in the Saigon area we also
have some 10 in transit warehouses where
we stage Cargill we're moving to the
depot
if not they we handle all ammunition for
explosive safety reasons we do not bring
ammunition ships here into the downtown
Saigon port area if nabe there are no
deep draft facilities for tying ships up
at piers the entire operation is done
from ships anchored in the stream onto
barges in from barges they're told by
the tugs up to six different barge
discharge sites for offloading the
barges on the trucks and then delivery
up to the various ammunition depots
belonging to the US Army the US Air
Force the Vietnamese Army or the
Vietnamese Air Force down at bum Tao we
have a another small port activity to
support the bunkhouse
support area here again we have no deep
draft berthing facilities and any shore
side activity we must discharge ships
from in the stream on buoys at Anchorage
into lighter äj-- from there it's total
char by barges and by tugs to barge
discharge sites where by cranes we take
it off the barges loaded onto trucks for
onward delivery into the Depot area some
of the problems that we encounter here
in operation in the Saigon port complex
the river system is not secure at night
all ships and our barges must transit
the river during daylight hours under
escort the VC controlled the area at
night and we do not move the ships into
the Saigon area during the hours of
darkness last September when he came in
and started operating in Saigon fort we
were confronted with a backlog of cargo
and a backlog of shipping awaiting
discharge
during last fall and winter the backlog
was absorbed today we are discharging
almost a hundred percent more cargo than
what we were last fall no military cargo
is delayed no ships are backlog cargo
comes into the Saigon port complex and
moves through the devil's without delay
last month here in Saigon
we handled almost a quarter of a million
tons of cargo
more docking facilities are under
construction for the swiftly growing
port complex at Cam Ranh Bay Vietnam
here the long pier is being built for
the loading and unloading of cargo the
pier is supported by ten caissons or
legs the caissons are driven into place
by a pile hammer which has a striking
force of 20,000 pounds preparations are
made for the installation of fenders to
protect the sides of the pier the
fenders each weighing 2,600 pounds are
made of metal with wooden slats a fender
is lowered into the water where it will
be secured to the caisson the de long
pier was designed by former Army
engineer Colonel Lewis B DeLong and has
proved successful in providing expanded
pier space for the vessels with military
cargo awaiting unloading in Cam Ranh Bay
11 July on the parade field at the
Pentagon ceremonies are held for the
newly created post of sergeant major of
the army - sergeant major William o
Wooldridge seen here with Army Chief of
Staff General Harold K Johnson goes the
honor of becoming the Army's highest
ranking in listin selected from among
more than 4,700 sergeants major now on
active duty Wooldridge will represent
the enlisted man on the army staff
serving as consultant on enlisted
matters to the chief of staff a salute
to the colors and the 19-gun salvo gets
the ceremonies underway the new army
sergeant major accompanied by his chief
troops the line the cracked third
infantry old guard from Fort Myer
participates in the occasion the
colorful ceremony symbolized the
dedication of the army enlisted man
since the founding of our nation
sergeant-major Wooldridge formerly of
the 1st Infantry Division has served in
the Army for 25 years his children are
among the spectators watching the
swearing-in proceeding general Johnson
administers the oath of the new office
while mrs. Wooldridge looks on in
keeping with army tradition
mrs. Wooldridge has given the honor of
helping general Johnson pin on the
insignia of her husband's new position
army secretary Stanley our research
congratulate s' the first sergeant major
to serve on the army general staff
Wooldridge also receives the good wishes
of general staff officers and
high-ranking civilians in the department
of the army
sharpshooters from 52 countries have
come on July 14th to Wiesbaden
Freudenberg Germany for the 39th contest
for the world shooting championships
high-ranking united states military
officers attend the events the German
shooting club is host for this year's
matches in association with the
international shooting union matches are
held for pistol rifle and trap shooting
the contest this year is the largest of
its kind ever held the United States and
the Soviet Union have entered full 40
member teams at the other end of the
scale are nations with only one
representative members of the West
German team make up the last contingent
in the parade
minister dr. Sen representing the West
German government delivers the welcoming
address 37 titles are to be awarded with
individual medals for winners on the
first day the women's trapshooting match
is held and the United States
representative Charlotte Birkin camp
places second at the small-bore pistol
range
Staff Sergeant Edwin Teague of the US
Air Force shoots a near-perfect score
following matches include the small bore
rifle English match from prone kneeling
and standing positions for women and men
and a new event for air rifles awards
are presented for individual and
combined team scores in the small bore
prone matches Lieutenant Margaret
Thompson US Women's Army Corps places
second and the u.s. women including miss
Thompson Patricia Kinsella and Mary Ann
Jensen wins silver medals with a
combined score for the men Marine
Warrant Officer David Boyd and William
Crillon placed first and third and with
captain Donald Adams and loans wigger of
Fort Benning capture the team trophy for
prone position lieutenant Gary Anderson
sets a new world record to win the
overall English math and with miss
Thompson wigger and Tommy pool wins the
team trophy for the 40 shot kneeling
match
Oh